les nuits partie zen des camions lourds
et de précieuses cargaisons
disparaissent tu as fait du temps à
toute l'industrie
celle qui va avoir un acheteur bas
niveau des valeurs qui vont chercher la
marchandise
c'est un fléau au québec et partout en
amérique du nord
on est tous des amis dans le transport
on veut tout savoir qu'est ce qui est à
lui pas ça se peut que ça m'arrive
demain c'est totalement rodé et c'est
souvent gérés par la crème organique
grâce aux réseaux sociaux des
camionneurs lancent leur propre enquête
on est postée sur facebook qui
s'assumait à se propager cercle humain
est-ce que c'est facebook qui doit faire
les anions pas les pièces qu'elles
assurent tous qu'ils avec benzema ne
rien faire on à la police pour faire
quoi pour nous aviser contacter nos
assurances lâche pas
on croise des poids lourds partout sur
la route et on n'est pas toujours
conscients de la valeur de ce qu'ils
transportent les criminels eux le savent
très bien parce que le vol de camion
c'est un fléau en amérique du nord luc
chartrand et catherine varga son parti
sur la route cet été au québec pour
suivre une vague de vols
ils ont aussi rencontré les camionneurs
qui se transforme en enquêteur et qui
réussissent parfois arrêter les voleurs
attend qu'on change le combier toi si tu
avais dit vol de cargaisons des vols de
remorques depuis l'automne dernier un
fléau
fils unique en son genre la radio des
camionneurs truck stop québec consacre
aujourd'hui son émission quotidienne au
vol de camion nous n'avez qu'à nairobi
gameiro à l'incertaine lumière près des
parts et des milliers d'arabes omettez
et gameiro legarda
les camionneurs parle d'épidémie les
cargaisons qu'il transporte et qui
peuvent valoir plusieurs centaines de
milliers de dollars attire des bandes de
voleurs professionnels
depuis le début de l'année un réseau est
particulièrement actif autour de
drummondville dans le centre du québec
une région où des vols surviennent
presque chaque semaine les camionneurs
part d'un fléau pour le contrer un
nouveau phénomène est apparu on a
commencé à le partager sur facebook avec
des partages open 1 4 mais les deux
jours on a beaucoup de tours mais le
parterre les camionneurs se mobilisent
le transport est intimement on est tous
des amis d'un transport qui ont depuis
compétition dans ce temps long depuis le
logo ses portes on veut tout savoir
qu'est ce qui est arrivé pas ça se peut
que ça m'arrive demain
dans la nuit du 1er au 2 janvier dans la
cour du transporteur rpm transit
tout semble calme mais la caméra numéro
de cape town intrus
le voleur et ses complices visiblement
pas trop nerveux s'empare de deux
camions de deux remorques et de leur
chargement
je fais mon inspection de coco mère à
tous les matins lorsque j'aurai on se
rend compte que quatre marques et les
soutes sécurité ont été endommagés
ouvert ses 28 camions sont munis de
traceur gps premier réflexe se
précipiter sur l'écran d'ordinateur
le temps presse les coûts d'une perte de
cargaisons et la réputation de
l'entreprise sont en jeu un bref signal
satellite a été émis sorti cette rosalie
de l'autoroute 20 on peut voir l'image
satellite on peut jouer et puis allez
voir exactement vu un coin des
boulevards lary mais au moment où le
signal est découvert le camion n'est
déjà plus là les traceurs ont été
neutralisés par les voleurs eux aussi
connaissent la technologie leur premier
geste est souvent de débrancher les
émetteurs ou d'embrouiller les on rôde
prince ne se contente pas d'appeler la
police
il va surtout miser sur un autre outil
on a posté sur facebook puis ça s'est
mis à se propager rapidement à partir
d'environ 8 heures 45
on est au courant qui m'inquiète deux
camions et un arrêt in sont nulles et
première réponse de facebook à sa vie
privée avec les réseaux sociaux les
camionneurs ont cessé d'être des
victimes passives en cas de vol à chaque
alerte facebook c'est une traînée de
poudre s'allonge pas de cadre aux
bénévoles d'être sa bonne allure chacin
géré autrement vauvert terrebonne
regardez le web sur le compte facebook
de rpm transitent les messages des
boules
j'ai vu ces deux camions par canal 80
elle à cet endroit en bordure de
l'autoroute
les voleurs ont abandonné les camions de
rpr il maison remplacés par d'autres
pour emporter les remorques ailleurs
comme dans la plupart des vols ce ne
sont pas les véhicules et ce qu'il
transporte qui intéresse les voleurs
il se trouve à wade génératrices des
génératrices industriels pour des
données du marché sans enfant qu'on
apercevait c'est pas des bêtes
génératrice de maisons camion remorque
et cargaisons un butin de plus d'un demi
million de dollars
yann vraiment dans le stationnement du
vaisseau à sainte-madeleine sortie 120e
route il vient de repérer une des
remorques chez rpm
on peut presque crié victoire merci
merci merci et notre famille facebook
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le lendemain dans la cour de notre peau
comme il y en a des dizaines à la chine
de camionneurs andric à balan patientes
pendant qu'on change sa remorque
je pense pourtant à le garder sur
facebook là je vois une annonce de télé
volet de camping cars et je régal 20
euros ça vient de sortir régler a bien
tracé tout fitch pris le téléphone j'ai
appelé à peine 37 pour les alizés je
pense que je viens de trouver ton très
laid andré cabale ans est un vigile en
montrant le rôle je regarde partout tout
le temps ça je me souviens quand je les
garderai un camion volé ça ne sent belle
tête à ça c'est facile tout le temps la
remorque avait déjà quitté les lieux
quand les policiers du spvm sont arrivés
la veille quatre voitures de police m'a
demandé quel d'élections que ça
participative elle a droit
ce n'est que le lendemain matin qu'un
autre camionneur repère la remorque vide
celle là j'aime me retrouver votre
marque à brassard
cette perte de cargaisons n'est pas sans
conséquence il est pour une compagnie
d'assurances qui vont s'occuper sans
charge donc qu'ils vont payer pour les
factures en bout de ligne ont bénéficié
de très bons tous de très bons prix puis
on a pensé dalton bart commun comme
plusieurs une cargaison perdu mais tout
de même deux camions et une remorque
encore charge et ont été retrouvés sains
et locaux présents ici charles pmc
facebook et rien d'autre nous a ramené
notre équipe
facebook est-il en train de battre la
police de vitesse
si le jardin de cellules personnes qui
ont partagé un vote de semi remorques
l'homme ayant un oeil à un homme est ici
le g8 193 partage en 30 minutes en ce
moment aux états unis on parle d'une
augmentation sur les taux de 25 % mâles
transports le vol est une des nombreuses
causes derrière la flambée récente du
coût des assurances et on vole
littéralement de tout principalement 4,5
choses entre autres beaucoup beaucoup
ces temps ci la viande il se voit les
noms alain de matériaux de construction
et bien sûr les deux trois principaux
l'électronique des boissons des siècles
six volets de la bière dans le secteur
de la rive sud de montréal cet été
et le lendemain il y avait des
commerçants dans montréal qué d'approché
pour liquider cette bière là alors on
parle d'une journée c'est totalement
rodé et c'est souvent souvent très
souvent gérés par le crime organisé la
semaine dernière du papier toilette
alors je pense que oui tout est absorbée
[Musique]
elle se dit dévoreuse d'asphalt en moto
ou au volant d'un camion lourd manon
l'italien fait partie d'un regroupement
d'administrateur de différents sites du
monde du camionnage
il y en a beaucoup des réseaux qui qui
partage des réseaux qui de liaison comme
chantait caméra bayavuge québec plus de
points à votre accueil aux caméras
camionneuse de points
kraft à québec ça certes le taux d'arrêt
à la charge nette des camions qui se
font voler l'os américain la pression de
ces partages croit-elle conduit beaucoup
de voleurs à abandonner leur but et ça
partage tellement avide sa présence
c'est ceux qui sont sur les réseaux
steve à la russie c'est soit qu'ils
voyent ceux-là on les fatigue un peu de
sa table de cuisine ou dans son salon à
l'ordinateur ou sur son téléphone
elle s'assure que les alertes se propage
les réseaux sociaux le groupe de
camionneurs cdd groupe de dix mille
15000 25 ans et toutes ses membres qui
partagent le savoir vivre
ils sont partout sont partout on est
partout
après la pause la police battus de
vitesse
[Musique]
et
mais les camions seront impressionnés de
voir un nourrisson gagne demain
dans sa musique
des camionneurs forment une vraie
communauté ils se rassemblent par
milliers dans l'une ou l'autre de la
douzaine de ces grands fête du camion
qui ont lieu chaque été à travers le
québec
ils ne craignent pas la fumée des
diesels n'ont pas eu des mac mon grand
prix des mac et
je continuais mac puis ccc malines avant
ils savent aussi faire briller ses
mastodonte avec un monde
[Musique]
moi je fais partie des comptes de
kanyama fait que souvent les personnes
qui se faisait voler des camions moi je
partageais gares aux quais vol de camion
numéro de plaque pas que ça se partage
et ça se propage
linda robert collectionne les trophées
de ces concours de beauté pour elle le
camion c'est plus qu'un outil de travail
une fierté des camionnettes
je me promène le monde marianne montrer
qu'ils savent c'est moins de chiens
fier aussi de faire rouler l'économie le
transport outil est au québec
une affaire de plus de 7 milliards de
dollars lavin québec et montréal c'est
le trans le footsie sur lequel
transitent des marchandises de partout
c'est le saint laurent des temps
modernes ce qui explique pourquoi c'est
le terrain de jeu des voleurs le jeu de
le découvrir
je viens de découvrir pendant notre
enquête un vol n'attend pas l'autre
nous nous sommes entretenus avec pas
moins d'une vingtaine de victimes de ces
vols
il est passé minuit
il se passe quelque chose dans la cour
de jijé rs boudreau de sainte eulalie
on cherche à faire démarrer des camions
qui ont tout couper la toussaint tout
coupé sotteville hommes et ils ont sorti
sortie des camions et remorques la
charge mais plutôt par ci par là
quatre camions 4e remorque et leurs 4
chargements de matériaux de construction
prennent le large
ils ont défoncé la clôture
sibal sa patte sens année on la gagne
après six minutes pour mener donné son
cv sortie de la cour où il ya tout
brésil équateur ce un parterre fax et
c'est vraiment pas chaud vers console
quinze kilomètres plus haut le margot
point des blocs de ciment qui avait
atteint les rifts arrachés
le rac à bloc que le kof mon physique
est chauffeur l'os bon mais je pense les
réseaux serait mieux de cléry
[Musique]
clôture fasseur gps caméra surveillance
rien ne semble décourager les voleurs
regardez bien
ceux ci vont prendre les grands moyens
pour ouvrir le portable
ce propriétaire croit pas ou clôture il
protège sa cour à sa façon puis depuis
l'année passée que j'ai un agent de
sécurité toute la nuit monterrey qui
arrêtent une fois de temps en temps les
menottes
les banquiers été dévoilé à la rituelle
depuis l'automne passé on a quatre
individus qu'on aime à noter qu'on
appelait la sûreté du québec qui son
poste en cours sauf que c'est valable
facilement ouais ça c'est un modèle
international 99 cents modèles 99 cents
c'est un modèle traditionnel avec une
moyenne vi ont percé des trous on plante
la vis dans le lot la porte d'un bar on
arrache laquelle la portée de bord et
ont fait la même chose que la suite on
prend un tournant mais ce constat
repenser en route
[Musique]
oh c'est pas des amateurs saucisses ou
non ça c'est selon lui le parc sont très
bien organisés puis il ya eu plusieurs
morts peut-être là pour porter toute
attente c'est un peu ce qui marche ou
est-ce que c'est facebook qui doit faire
les avions passent les pièces que la
sûreté du québec body benoît on n'évite
pas les affaires leur justice est faite
à la sûreté du québec
l'idée de voir la population mené ses
propres enquêtes est accueillie avec
réserve il faut savoir que l'information
qui est diffusée rapidement des prix
n'est pas enquêté n'est pas validé nous
ce qu'on demande c'est aux gens de
partager les informations qui ont été
validés par les autorités policières
mais la raison même du succès de
facebook c'est la diffusion instantanée
des alertes
matthieu le blond arrive avec le
mastodonte qui s'est fait voler ici même
il ya un mois de ça commençait à me dire
où c'est que le monde avait vu mon
camion rouge
je vais déposer à 40 direction montréal
donc les bévues dans le cas de pertes
civiles
je lis remarquer accosté restreinte et
ce lac 4 et j'accroche je suis très
content je trouve un bon qui remarquable
aussi dossiers noirs les styles se
démarque des autres camions ils avaient
beaucoup tu l'avais vu ce qu'ils
disaient on le remarque et parce qu'ils
étaient beaux morale de l'histoire
impôts camions se fera remarquer et
retrouver plus facilement par rapport
aux polices belges font leur travail
paris c'est long il fallu que je change
de poste de police même une secousse
bello ne pas faire un seul camion ont
été volés à victo non mais je sais
qu'ils étaient volés victor miranda
berthierville
comme pour beaucoup d'autres c'est
facebook qui a fait le travail
c'est à recommencer à ça ça recommence
et je penche pas très sûr je pense que
je mettrais sur facebook avant d'appeler
la police
la vérité c'est que les réseaux bat de
plus en plus la police de vitesse on
sait les réseaux sociaux sont très
populaires lige apple veut apercevoir
rapidement l'information se propage
rapidement
donc je veux savoir à placer en fait on
est par contre tout de même un peu plus
d'enthousiasmé chez les assureurs à 100%
c'est les assureurs mais les courtiers
et les enquêteurs vont l'encourager
totalement puisque ça va nous permettre
souvent de retrouver la marchandise plus
rapidement que si on avait fait affaire
avec un service de police tout le monde
communiquent ensemble puis finalement on
appelle les polices ponzi mais la
remorque est tatel place à lavaltrie
souvent on retrouve le cumin puis il n'y
a pas eu de vol finalement n'y aura pas
de réclamations à faire payer à l'asra
[Musique]
les policiers bénéficient eux aussi des
retombées des réseaux sociaux
deux présumés voleurs ont été arrêtés
ici même en présence de remorques paul
est repéré par un usager de facebook
dans deux maximum 4 on avait un bon
samaritain qui nous avait dit que notre
manque était le policier c'est parti
entre l'armor voilée et puis le camion
et puis on jette ainsi juste en train de
manger venus arrêter juste ici en face
comme des faits
[Musique]
incroyable la vitesse des réseaux
sociaux
merci d'avoir partagé en si grand nombre
un des individus arrêtés à cliquer saint
germain est un récidiviste du vol et du
recel de camions il est en attente de
procès et encourt une peine maximale de
10 ans de prison
c'est un gars du coin comme la plupart
des accusés pour ce genre de clip
ils sont nombreux en 2016 et 2017
seulement la sûreté du québec a démonté
deux réseaux une quarantaine
d'arrestations ont eu lieu
j'espère que c'est fini mais ça
m'étonnerait
en effet pour nicole coderre
propriétaires de locations énergie à
drummondville
ça semble plutôt ne pas vouloir finir
elle vient de subir un troisième vol
cette année
les transporteurs ont déjà tellement
difficultés à gérer tout ce que
l'industrie du transport exige sa entre
le gérer le favori des équipements de
perdre le caco de payer des franchises a
fait ce temps à toute l'industrie teint
qui va avoir un acheteur bailly va voir
des valeurs qui ont cherché la
marchandise c'est l'offre et la demande
si on peut éliminer les acheteurs on
repère arrivé à contrecarrer justement
alors plein essor c'est la job de la
sûreté du québec
[Musique]